all right it is time for drew's news
your daily trip to the good news soft
serve machine
ooh yum i know and with me at the desk
is my little sugar cone ross
matthews hi
everybody i used to work at mcdonald's i
was triple threat drive-thru register
and grill and i would make i knew how to
do the little flip of the wrist so it
would get that perfect little curl at
the top i know
you are the perfect little girl
thank you for noticing
i pick up what you're putting down
well we're going to start with an icon
of the silver screen she's got a
permanent spot in the hall of fame of
our hearts jamie lee curtis
she has a wild new movie out
with the amazing actress and action star
michelle yo called everything everywhere
all at once and it's a big ball of
sci-fi action comedy drama i guess every
tone in the book and glamour reports
that jamie told the directors um from
the start that she didn't want to
conceal a darn thing when it came to her
body here she is as deirdre bo bierdra
an irs auditor
jamie said quote i've been sucking in my
stomach since i was 11 and i
specifically decided to relinquish and
release every muscle that i use to
clench and hide the reality yes
please
i love her
so i mean who loves jamie lee curtis
hello
hello and you think about
she has kept it so real for so long now
you know i mean she's always managed to
be gorgeous and hilarious and talented
and dramatic in all of it and she did it
in a way that was classy and now i love
that she is just embracing exactly who
she is and and bringing that to her
artistry yeah but do you remember like
the movie perfect with john travolta oh
yeah the workout instructor uh-huh yeah
of course i mean
there's so many you did have like i mean
the movie was called like perfect with a
picture of her body so what do you do
when your movie when your body is on a
poster that says perfect exactly and
then you're supposed to live up to that
for the rest of your life well like and
even in true lies remember she's in that
little black dress that's like so tiny
all right next up uh we have an
incredible story and you actually found
this story and it just blew me away you
know it really shows the human family
coming together in the toughest of times
people reports a group of clowns from
israel traveled to moldova to bring some
joy and laughter to ukrainian children
crossing the border with their families
the clowns are from the dream doctors
project it it's a group of professional
medical clowns i didn't know there were
medical clowns but there are and they
provide laughter and therapy to medical
patients veterans and holocaust
survivors back home and the clowns say
they might not speak ukrainian but
humor is universal and that is so true
and
my favorite story i love it i love it i
love it i'm so glad we got to report on
it no words that i could ever say could
match up to the majesty of them thank
you for doing what you're doing thank
you so much
agreed
[Music]
you